- Well there's something
else that I thought
was kinda cool that you're doing.
So you have, it's a new
line at Wal-Mart, right?
A new clothing line?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Talk to me about that.
That's amazing, (talking over each other)
that's a huge brand.
- I know, you know, it's funny.
When I was home, I drove by the Wal-Mart
that my mom and I had to walk to
because my mom's car didn't work.
- Oh!
- You know, and it was super far.
I mean, it felt like 10 miles.
I think it was only four, but regardless.
I was like, "Oh my gosh,
I have this partnership
"with a brand that I've been, you know,
"literally shopping at forever."
But when I was a young
kid, a chubby little girl,
they didn't have cute clothes.
There weren't cute girl
clothes for chubby girls.
Or for anybody that was sort of outside
of a straight size, just generally.
And now that they are
incorporating such incredible,
it's affordable, but it's also trendy.
And I think that's really important,
'cause I think when we
feel good, we do good
and all of that, it's
all sort of encompassing.
And so when I was even
approached by Wal-Mart,
I was like, "Oh well, yeah,
like this makes sense for me
"because it's something
that I think is just..."
- I think it's real, that's what I like.
It's believable, it's
like, I'm the same girl.
I shopped there too, growing up.
I think, you know, for some people,
they hear like, "Oh well you don't need
"to be trendy, like that's not important."
It's like, you don't realize
how important that is
unless you don't fit in that circle.
You don't realize how
devastating that is for a kid.
You know, even me, I grew up,
you know, with Payless shoes
and everybody else had
Nikes and it was like,
my shoes were the ones
that made black marks
all over the basketball court.
And those kind of things
count and that really does,
you know, you start recognizing
your life and your being
as less than.
- Yeah.
- And so I think that
it's really important
and awesome that they reached out to you
because you represent a lot
of the American community
and the world community.
And so I think it's really important that
when any of us do these sponsored things
or these endorsements or these deals,
that it's believable and it's real.
And that's what I really loved about it,
so thank you for doing it, it's cool.
- Yeah, I'm super grateful
and it's funny how,
you know, life happens and
how it all kind of pulls in.
I'm like, "Oh, I would never
have thought, you know,
"a girl struggling (chuckles)
in Gainesville, Florida would,
"you know, have sort of a really
"important partnership with--"
- Yeah, and can create such an impact
for other little girls in Gainesville
that are going through the same thing, so.
- Right!
- I think that's the coolest
thing we're able to do
with whatever you wanna call this,
our little version of superpowers, so.
(laughing)